RYAN BUSH: 13th voice.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Sounds are the
dream [? kissing. ?]
RYAN BUSH: Welcome to the
Cannaiseur Dinner Series--
hopefully, the first of many.
COREEN CARROLL: The
cannaiseur event
is about bringing
people together
that are interested in
cannabis, but creating
an environment that doesn't
exemplify the stoner.
We're doing four
courses, starting off
with a medicated amuse-bouche
before the four courses.
And in between each
course, we will be doing
an [? inner-metzo ?]
of cannabis joints.
The feeling of the cannabis
that it's going to create,
it's more elevated,
more elegant,
and it's going to create a cool
feeling throughout the evening.
Everyone coming to the
cannaiseur dinner series
tonight will have a prop
215 medical marijuana
recommendation.
The types of people that are
going to be at this event
are marijuana
lawyers, activists,
people who are fans of cannabis
and want to change the stigma,
and want to experience
cannabis in a different way.
What you have on your
plate is some [INAUDIBLE]
of three different
types of cucumbers, one
that's infused with beet juice.
Then you have a Persian one,
as well as a Japanese style.
Then you have a mustard
sauce and a dill oil.
We hope that events
like this will
create a better and cooler
environment for people
to come and share
cannabis together.
You don't always have to go
to a bar and have drinks.
You can just smoke a joint
and meet a new friend.
SPEAKER 3: If you
enjoyed this episode
and aren't already a
subscriber to Seeker Stories,
click here to stay up to
date on all of our latest
short documentaries.
And for another episode,
please click here to watch now.
SPEAKER 4: The disconnection
from distraction
gets your brain daydreaming.
When you're in
daydreaming mode, you
start to do a little bit
of the lateral thinking,
so you start connecting
this, to that, to this.
And you start to go
through the aha moments.
And if you are lucky enough
to have the camera around,
you're capturing
that real time flow.
It's creativity
happening in real time.